so we're gonna start off with sector all
right and you'll see that we got lk 99
which is his official model right all
right so we'll go on into here and who
do we want to beat up all right and I'm
sure everybody wants to see the pool so
let's go ahead and do the pet as well
the pit is making a comeback into MKX L
and it's beautiful it looks incredible
as well that was visually as a stage
we're doing proud we're getting some
people in the background so we are we're
doing practice mode for now but the
twins are gonna play here a little bit
again look we disappointed so many
you'll get your intros later you're
impatient all right
so it's back - is this sweet little
flippy thing here right now we've got
sectors so he's got all your base sector
moves plus they're a little bit enhanced
because we got to mix it up so yeah like
in most of our combat cast will always
show like what special moves that the
characters share now because these are
all you know the different robots right
don't share any special move no they
really do not share they shared some
special moves so coming back is the
straight missile right now we can exit
and it does this super for missile magma
craziness right there
and he's got his back rockets but you
can actually direct them in different
distances so he can put it behind the
opponent or of course you can put it in
front of the opponent or directly on
them so you guys would see almost
immediately the the projectile side of
sector is very much how it used to be he
had the straight missile he has the
upper so what happens if you meet a burn
the up missile there Oh the up missile
you say let me go ahead and do it and
there it is homing missiles boys it's
come back all we saw just chipped that
make now which side didn't used to do
okay
of course he's got his telepon CH coming
right back and you can exit if I could
press the right trigger and that'll
bounce it for you to do a follow-up
attack if I could do that but you know
I'm not professional come on let me let
me just give a little option selector
your real quickly
absolutely we are playing on a larger TV
which has a little bit of a little of
lag so the combos are gonna be a little
it's still are we might drop compos
large pieces are already good to go
absolutely absolutely so like we said
he's got his telepon coming back e^x e^x
tell a punch coming back and of course
you can follow up with another combo all
right
and then what's special to MK X is he's
got the sweet air - can only be done
airborne I would like to have rocky
while he's in the air and so one thing
that you'll notice with each one of
these variations is they have a lot of
common combos but they also have a lot
of variations specific combos as well so
the team did a really good job - of
giving the the specials I mean that the
strings they have their own personality
absolutely so he's got this one combo
that he has this chest bursts that comes
out that's only exclusive to sector he
did actually have that string in Mortal
Kombat 9 as well just to remind before
yet one final move as well his flame
burner
of course the how can I forget that's
why we have you here and so of course
that is coming back we stand anymore
sorry guys it does not ppj thought the
same thing as well so you can do the ex1
and i could do it look at that so you
could use that it's like an anti-air you
can use it just quick getaway one good
thing about that move - is it it's
Harvard exactly that that the AMIA burn
flame burner has got armor and hits
multiple times but does armor break so
functions really well basic just as a
get off me tool that sector always
lacked
in more come at 9 but he has got an X so
and he has these reaching like blasters
on his hands - which I believe he also
had back in MK 9 that looks like his own
black wonder I do how do you special
console that I can't I could try we'll
see oh gosh
I'll let you do that you're the
professionals yeah this is not working
for me we do that one later yeah and
then of course even I'm just as low you
C's got a little blaster as well so it
gives them that little extra reach as
well so I'm gonna let you do some swaggy
combo so you want to do it well I know
alright so you see what you can pull off
here
it's see the pressures real buy into a
broker
just like vintage is a night his combos
event are virtually very very similar
you have the starter which goes in
teleport commode for the event teleport
and follow-up whether you want you can
do damage based when I scooped up this
off allows you to get pressure obvious
you combine that with your zoning which
be cheap way this parts are pretty
really quickly another cool thing so you
tease pretty strong and so on yes
exactly a little bit when you break it
down sector was always a very strong
space control character but the fact
that it starts up quicker now you can
control the missiles go they hit
multiple times which will serve armor
breaking putts gonna give there are and
it will hit multiple times but the cool
thing about his teleport is by itself
already pay attention to the speed
ensnare boys return so they've developed
neat when you meet it been to teleport
starts up way quicker and that allows
you to feel off for another thing don't
be having this are whatever you want to
do don't show it all don't give it all
to them alright that was good alright so
I can't hear you
so we're gonna get up ahead and go into
Cyrax alright so let's do it let's do it
let's do an x-ray robot oh absolutely
you're right one thing that is also with
each variation they have their own into
for the x-ray so sector has its more
traditional mk9 so does Cyrax
and smoking is kind of like a hybrid so
we'll get into that too nice throws too
right that's pretty much exactly the
same as Mortal Kombat no an x-ray a
joint missile does where is it alright I
know you're excited so let's go ahead
and get into siren so you ready
absolutely alright here we go alright so
you'll notice right off the bat he's
yellow
alright so that's a really good show of
which variation were coming back of
course are his bombs now go ahead and
break their hearts now they're low now
guys they're no longer unblockable one
thing definitely worth mentioning at mp9
key did
some crazy damage possibilities through
the unblockable bombs they are now low
these guys just ground bombs coming back
you can do a mid one you can shoot one
far away from your opponent or you can
put one right in front of you again just
like in pain just like mk9 what you also
can do is the DX version which will
there we go which will detonate
instantly so otherwise they kind of have
to time out right and you've got to have
that proper time if you'll find those
set up pretty quick it's just to get
that standard launching capability
really absolutely n of course his
buzzsaw is back
again amid now used to be an overhead
uh-huh and you can exit if I could do it
and it'll actually hold the opponent in
the air for a little bit as well he's
got his teleport or he's got his air
grab which you can do in the air and
just kind of give away or get towards
your opponent do it off the ground he's
got his teleport and he's got his e^x
tell I like how you showed the air grab
without ever air grabbing oh yeah my bad
here we go oh yeah there we go as long
as the opponents in their borne state
that one combo hasn't used it and and
you could do the ex1 which will do it
additional bouncing so you continue your
combos right like with that man that
rings onto the net right and everybody
was so happy when they saw the net
coming back so the answer the questions
what does the e X net do it drains ball
from the opponent once again it's back
alright great rains ha ha ha ba now used
to join the 4 ball but now drains house
so you basically spend a bar to get rid
of half of those and so when trap them
right and so what's new with cyrex is
he's also got some air bombs so it's not
it he just doesn't cover the ground he
also covers the air so you can set up
all sorts of different little tricks but
that's it right like the obvious the
ground bombs being alone they're myths
like they're just standard blocks the
air ones but they cover a more practical
ground obviously in the air
we jump in us but it's just a really
sell out that minefield will be quite
interesting moving into where certain
pairs right and so I'm just like the
ground bombs if you set them up they
instantly detonate otherwise you kind of
just have to you know wait for it to for
the time out so if you're playing with
Cyrax what is your sort of game plan
well I mean it is very early to tell
right again much like sector it is very
traditional more come back nine you know
the bombs are gonna be a problem people
to deal with on hit they launched so
again you know your net being a massive
projectile again is going to be quite
difficult for people to get around right
teleporting makes you really mobile so
just general I mean especially if it
turns out he's got some really good
normal some really good strings then I'm
definitely thinking you can play him the
way we used to right and he has he
actually does have some strings of his
own as well we can right so just like
how sector head is one combo with the
chest that would have an explosion he
shoots out a bomb out of his chest he
also has some specific buzzsaw combos as
well there we go
similar to what he had an MK 9 and see
if I could do it he's got his back to
which everybody I'm sure was waiting to
know if that came back was very nice
she's like it okay so for the most part
that's Iraq's but it wouldn't be fair
unless you got to show some stuff ah
thank you very much no he's been
practicing this quite religiously so
hopefully nothing is right this is what
consider a standard MP 9 sorry so string
into bomb and JP oh my word and he's a
professional commentator now mate they
are very high politics
so as you can see it's just a mixture of
comboing off the bomb continuing the
juggle they're definitely what you talk
to an end k9 but this is an MK 9 so
let's see if I can maybe do this the
thing is one thing just keep this in
mind I'm ending it in the grab that grab
can be meter burns to another launcher
or even let's just say I get a standard
I'll heat on the ground [ __ ] you up Bob
overhead and that bombs are low so
that's overhead low that's right and in
the bomb and then like do your thing and
maybe try and get some kind of you know
follow-up from there back right so don't
show it all off you guys will have your
moment all right so here we go we got
smoke coming back now this robot smoke
is kind of like a hybrid of the human
smoke and the classic ultimate mk3 smoke
all right so all right so we've got his
spears it is three tridents that come
out of the pouch I just want to stare
playing three tridents that come out of
his chest
now you can exit and it'll keep your
opponents standing so you can just kind
of follow up with whatever you'd like at
that point in MK 9 he had these smoke
bombs and of course those are coming
back as well you can change the distance
you can make it coming close you can
make it go behind them or you can make
them track by just doing the traditional
one but he's got his air throw coming
back as well and then he has his
teleport
that was the ex1 I'm showing too much
I'm sorry his normal one we'll just do
the straight knockdown I think a single
barrel and I would argue it's too much
it's too much if anything no and so the
next one will pop them back up you can
spear and you can continue to combo but
you might be able to yeah not me you're
not me
and another thing that comes back is his
ability to phase through the opponent
now one thing deaf means isn't taken out
of an MK 9 you could definitely do that
a lot
but it was very hard to deal with it now
takes your stamina to perform right
let's the smoke away and smoke the world
also yep as you watched see the stamina
meter grows down right and of course you
can e^x them but one more are you ready
he can disappear can you do that an MP 9
could he do that in MK 9 I'm sure he
could I'm pretty sure he could okay
let's stop walking down memory lane guys
alright okay so he can go completely
invisible as well now what's special
about smoke is he has a few more
exclusive strings than some of the other
characters things that might look
familiar things that might look familiar
so if you do it with one of these one of
his combos it'll actually throw a smoke
bomb down from there you can actually
just follow up with the sphere you can
follow up with the teleport you do a
sweep you can mix up yep you can do an
overhead whatever you want from there he
also has this which is very similar to
his teleport if I could do it his
teleport in MK 9 I'm getting there I
swear I will but you can see the idea is
just know that these moves are back he's
clearly got these like universal things
and a few tribal knowledge base also got
his own smoke effects mixed ups crazy
teleport ninja stuff right right and for
the most part that's it but he has a
couple other like special things like
his neutral jumps and stuff like that
have this extra smoke burst to it that
gives them additional reach and there's
a few other little combo tweaks as well
that you can do but that's pretty much
smoke
you